[Music]
the last one that's driving everyone
crazy including us
is
the biden administration
has
completely lost their minds and changed
the tax the child tax credit to the
point that no human can understand it
and um
we were we were considering attempting
to explain it
but it's just not explainable on the
radio so here's the thing the tax credit
for a kid under 17 if you have children
used to be two thousand dollars
and now tax credit is different than a
tax deduction a tax credit comes off
your tax bill
so if you had a three thousand dollar
tax bill and you had a two one child you
reduce it by two thousand dollars and
you only have one thousand our tax bill
that's how credit works it's an actual
dollar for dollar a deduction is not not
the same thing
now
here's the thing
the the credit
used to work before the american rescue
plan
which is a stupid name when did that
come in was that you're in covet though
that was 2020. that was true
that was trump
the government's coming to rescue you
plan
oh help me lord
and so before before the only option was
to claim your tax credit when you filed
your income taxes
now
you file your tax credit and it all
changed in 2021 for and of course again
yeah you're gonna file it this this
spring yes to get your tax credit and
uh
now it is thirty six hundred dollars for
kids zero to five
uh three thousand dollars for kids six
to seventeen and five 500 for kids age
18 to 24 who claim who you claim as a
dependent because they're enrolled in
college so if you've got a 21 year old
you can claim them now 500 worth
um
just because they are dependent on you
they're not filing in their own tax
returns for any reason in that case
which is would be dumb on a whole lot of
fronts uh but anyway they could do that
yeah
so
this is
unbelievably convoluted and complicated
and
um
i wish there was a way i could just be
brilliant and make it simple for you but
it's impossible because they've just
added another another volume to the tax
code to try to confuse the crap out of
you so
um
what i would tell you to do on this is
there's a blog at ramseysolutions.com
and if you want to nerd out and go into
the details
there's a full blog on the child tax
credit changes
and if you want to nerd out you can read
through it and it is actually you will
actually understand we wrote it in a way
where you can actually understand it um
but i just don't think it translates to
me reading it over the radio so i'm not
going to do it so but the bottom line is
the tax child tax credits are larger
than they used to be they're broader
than they used to be the way you receive
them is even different the way you
receive them is different um it's worth
checking into because you're getting
more money in most cases than you used
to get
but you need to understand it and so do
the investigation don't just let this
happen to you
and then you'll figure out how awful it
is when the government comes to your
rescue